pas
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat pour une matinée
spéciale consacrée aux travaux de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur la
lutte contre le dopage
mercredi dernier les sénateurs ont
auditionné denis masseglia c'était la
veille de sa réélection à la tête du
comité national olympique et sportif
français
audition que je vous propose de suivre
tout de suite chers collègues voulaient
bien on replace nous auditionnons
maintenant monsieur denis masseglia
président du comité national olympique
et sportif français cnosf
je rappelle une ultime fois puisque
c'est la dernière audition aujourd'hui
au public qu'il n'y a aucune
manifestation possible d'approbation ou
de désapprobation et je dois informer
les personnes auditionnées que à faux
témoignage devant une autre commission
seraient passibles de sanctions pénales
mais monsieur nothing in house a
l'habitude de nous rendre visite et nous
vous en remercions encore je vais vous
demander parce que c'est la procédure
des commissions d'enquêté de la vérité
toute la vérité de lever la main droite
et tenir je le jure je le jure merci se
trouvait dans le déroulement concret de
notre rencontre c'est de vous donner la
parole pendant un quart d'heure l'ours
est pas plus ou moins deux minutes
prenez le temps qu'il faut mais servent
de l'ordre d'un quart d'heure pour nous
dire quel est votre sentiment sur la
lutte contre le dopage et
ensuite les membres de la commission
présent à commencer par notre rapporteur
que vous connaissez également très bien
seront chargés nous poser quelques
questions complémentaires pour essayer
de parfaire notre connaissance en la
matière donc monsieur président nous
vous écoutons vous avez la parole merci
alors si vous le voulez bien je pense
que on peut commencer puisque
l'interrogation première est de donner
le sentiment par rapport à la lutte
contre le dopage de dire que pour moi
lutte contre le dopage santé des
sportifs lutte contre l'autre fléau qui
est la suspicion de dopage sont autant
de paramètres qui sont liés et que
finalement compte tenu de tout ce que
l'on a vécu il ya une nécessité absolue
qui consiste à se dire que tout
l'arsenal que l'on peut mettre en oeuvre
pour regarder un sport qui soit le plus
propre possible le plus en adéquation
avec les valeurs qu'ils apportent à
l'être humain
cet arsenal est un mal nécessaire avec
lequel il faut vivre même si parfois
cela crée des contraintes et j'espère
que finalement les progrès à la fois de
la législation et de la science serons
d'abord au service du sport et de
l'individu plutôt qu'au service de ceux
qui voudraient tricher pour arriver à en
tirer profit
alors il ya plusieurs aspects qui
doivent intervenir d'abord pense que ça
rejoint la problématique j'ai indiqué à
de multiples de multiples reprises pour
moi
tout commence lorsqu'on est jeune c'est
à dire que de la même manière qu'on doit
inculquer un jeune l'envi de faire du
sport et je voudrais juste préciser même
si c'est un sans rapport avec le dopage
qui a un jeune sur trois en france qui
fait pas de sport et que ça devrait être
une des interrogations prioritaire de
tous les gouvernants ceci étant dit si
je reprends tout commence au plus jeune
âge et de la même manière qu'on doit
inciter les jeunes à faire du sport on
doit aussi sensibiliser ceux qui en
forme et qui font de la compétition au
fait que d'abord le sport c'est une
pratique qui se fait avec de la loyauté
et du respect et que par ailleurs il ya
aussi à travers des pratiques illicites
la mise en danger non seulement de
soi-même mais aussi de
ce qui fait le fondement pour lequel les
jeunes s'engagent à savoir une pratique
loyale donc ne pas oublier que les
aspects de prévention sont un des
moyennes incontournable de lutter contre
le fléau du dopage
ensuite lorsque launay avec la lutte
antidopage il ya à la fois tout ce qui
concerne les mesures qui sont prises
pour les sportifs de haut niveau et
celles qui peuvent intervenir pour les
pratiquants dit de deuxième niveau et
qui sont contrôlés aussi parce que c'est
nécessaire dont les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre pour les uns et les autres ne
peuvent pas être mis sur le même pied et
pour ce qui concerne la pratique des
sportifs de haut niveau il est évident
qu et c'est souvent le cas dans les
interviews que les athlètes à cordes
il ya un prix à payer à ce que les
contrôles et les dispositifs même s'ils
sont contraignants sont la meilleure
garantie pour que le sport qui est
pratiqué ne souffre alors on va dire
d'aucune suspicion c'est un bien grand
mot mais en tout cas de suspicion ou que
la suspicion soit la moindre possible
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler
les athlètes sur les contraintes que
posait le système adams
bon ils n'ont pas tous la même opinion
et à la limite je dirais que c'est assez
logique que les sportives ne s'exprime
pas d'une même voix sur un sujet comme
celui-ci il n'empêche que je pense que
je trouve que majoritairement il
s'exprime pour le fait que même si ça
leur crée quelques difficultés c'est une
manière pour eux deux
gardez à l'esprit un sport propre qui
est je pense quelque chose de
satisfaisant quand on les entend
s'exprimer ainsi
maintenant je crois qu'il faut le dire
comme beaucoup d'autres l'ont dit
auparavant certainement nul n'est à
l'abri de d'une initiative personnelle
ou de chimère que l'on peut faire
briller auprès de quelqu'un qui a un
moment et peut-être sensibles à un
discours qui peut lui être tenu comme
quoi ils pourraient améliorer ses
performances par tel ou tel moyen dont
en particulier des moyennes dit crain
moderne qui pourraient être des produits
indétectables d'arles le contexte actuel
ce qui me semble être important aussi a
souligné
c'est le fait que haneya admis que les
techniques de congélation de l'uriné du
ca on pouvait jusqu'à un délai de huit
ans permettre de détecter des produits
qui à l'instar du prélèvement sont
indétectables et qui représente au cas
où ils seraient décelées par la suite
une formidable épée de damoclès sur la
tête de celles et de ceux qui auraient
contrevenu aux règles ça me semble être
quand même un élément essentiel et on a
vu des athlètes disqualifié et
sanctionner un an deux ans voire trois
ans après je pense que cet exemple là
est quelque chose d'extrêmement positif
si je peux me permettre l'adjectif pour
l'efficacité de la lutte en kit anti
dopage et que cela constitue pour les
apprentis sorciers une forme de doute
quant à l'efficacité de ce qu'il
pourrait mettre en oeuvre maintenant on
n'échappera pas à ce que certains se
disent que le produit qu'ils pourraient
utiliser et tellement à indétectable ou
tellement en avance que
jamais de la vie etc si je prends le
fruit de l'expérience au delà des
athlètes qui ont pu être sanctionné
grâce à des prélèvements congelé il ya
aussi la prise de conscience pour
beaucoup du fait que l'omerta passé
n'est plus aussi d'actualité et si lance
armstrong est tombé c'est pas parce
qu'on a détecté des produits interdits
dans des échantillons congelés c'est
parce que le poids de la conscience a
fait qu' il a été lui-même dénoncé par
d'autres et donc ce contexte là me
semble aussi être être important il y a
il ya quelque part une forme de comment
dire une forme c'est le mot prise de
conscience qui me semble le plus adapté
dans celles et ceux qui ne resteront pas
complice un système pour peu qu'ils en
aient connaissance alors je ne veux pas
être non plus dans un contexte de
naïveté absolue ou bienne d'angélisme la
tricherie fait partie aussi de la nature
humaine
il n'empêche que au plus on le prend en
amont au plus on sensibilise et au plus
on menace de sanctions on va dire que
moins il y aura de risques et que de ce
point de vue là moi je fais partie de
ceux qui indique qu' il ya eu d'énormes
progrès qui ont été faits en matière de
lutte antidopage et par là même en
matière de l'autre fléau qui pour moi
est important à souligner qui est celui
de la suspicion de dopage parce qu'il ne
faudrait pas que
l'on pense qu'il ya que les vainqueurs
qui peuvent être dopé et que ceux qui
perd 2 e sont forcément parfaitement
propre il peut y avoir aussi dans ceux
qui perdent des gens qui sont dopés et
fort heureusement dans ce qu'ils gagnent
des gens qui ne le doivent qu'à leur
talent et à leur travail
voilà donc ceci étant dit nul n'est à
l'abri de
d'une approche individuelle ça nécessite
forcément une sensibilisation permanente
notamment chez les jeunes ça nécessite
aussi une approche indéniable sur le
plan de la fiabilité technique et
médical et de ce point de vue là à la
fois le passeport biologique et
l'établissement de paramètres
incontestable fait aussi partie des
progrès sur lesquels on peut s'appuyer
pour indiquer que la lutte antidopage a
fait d'incontestables progrès en tout
cas tout ce qui peut être dissuasif
comme mesure est à souligner et à
prendre en considération
maintenant il ya aussi un autre
paramètre sur lequel personnellement
c'est une opinion et où je ne suis pas
sûr qu'elle soit forcément partagé
autant je suis contre une sanction
pénale du type peine de prison parce que
celui qui a triché c'est quand même pas
un hors la loi au même titre que
d'autres otages il ya un préjudice à
l'image du sport pour celui qui a triché
que ce soit par le dopage ou par la
corruption et il ne me semblerait pas
inopportune d'imaginer des sanctions
financières à l'égard de ceux qui sont
accusés
alors après il faut évidemment pesé les
conditions dans lesquelles se seraient
produits mais moi je suis favorable en
tous cas ce qui est des sanctions
financières pour atteinte à l'image du
sport que ce soit en matière de dopage
de corruption ou autres ou de violence
même il vous de violence parce que la
violence est aussi partie des aspects
pervers sur lesquels on doit souligner
la nécessité de lutter merci le
président avant de donner la parole
notre rapporteur jean jacques lozach
je souhaite que nous vous posions une
première question quelle appréciation
portez vous sur l'engagement du cio à
travers sa commission médicale dans la
lutte contre le dopage pour vous ces
moyens sont ils ces moyens humains et
financiers sont ils suffisants
alors d'abord on peut souligner le cio a
été en position extrêmement volontariste
pour créer l'agencé mondiale antidopage
et harmonisée en quelque sorte entre les
différents sports à la fois l'arsenal
des sanctions et les politiques de
prévention
donc il faut toujours indiqué qu'il n'en
fait pas assez et c'est mais je pense
que ça la volonté du co2
de mettre en avant
certain nombre de mesures on ne serait
pas arrivé on progrès dont je me faisait
l'écho précédemment certes certes pour
qu'il le fasse
il a fallu qu'il y ait des cas donc un
moment il a fallu
on va dire qu' il y ait des difficultés
suffisamment importante suffisamment
médiatisé suffisamment connue pour que
la réaction soit à la mesure du fléau
ce qu'on pourrait lui reprocher c'est de
ne pas l'avoir fait de manière plus
anticipé mais pas parodier ce qui avait
été dit un jour tout le monde savait
mais personne ne savait c'est vrai que
c'est un reproche qui peut être fait
mais à beaucoup comme quoi un moment
l'absence de preuve absolue fait que les
présomptions ne doivent pas valoir une
action qui peut aussi être parfois
synonyme de difficultés je me rappelle
c'est je ne sais plus en quelle année
mais parce que vous on pourrait
retrouver le détail de la sphère où la
fédération internationale d'athlétisme
se sentait complètement démuni par
rapport à battre grenoble ce qui lui
avait parlé par l'intermédiaire de
tribunaux américaine la capacité de m la
fédération d'athlétisme en réelle
difficulté financière donc ça fait
réfléchir
celui à qui incombe la sanction par
rapport aux conséquences que la sanction
peut lui faire subir du point de vue de
son existence même donc il ya il ya une
logique aussi dans la réflexion que le
dirigeant sportif peut avoir non pas
dans sa volonté de lutter mais dans
l'appréciation des risques encourus
notamment par rapport à une décision de
justice qui pourrait lui être
défavorable non pas sur le fond mais sur
la forme et et c'est valable aussi pour
le cio parce que personne n'est à l'abri
c'est pour ça que le fait d'avoir
associé les états à une cause
humanitaire qui est la lutte contre le
dopage fait qu' il ya plus de garanties
par rapport à la solvabilité d'un
organisme qui quels qu'ils soient
prendre des risques à partir du moment
où ils s'attaquent à un individu
jean jacques lozach oui président merci
pour votre contribution à notre
réflexion concernant les lutte
antidopage une question que l'on pose
traditionnellement quand on a affaire à
des uns des parcours comme les vôtres
c'est à dire être un sportif de haut
niveau avant d'exercer des
responsabilités fédérales est ce que
justement lorsque vous vous pratiquer
l'aviron vous aviez été personnellement
confrontés à des problèmes de dopage
est-ce que l'aviron peut faire
éventuellement partie des sports risques
au regard de cette incitation à recourir
au dopage alors à titre personnel mon
meilleur titre de gloire c'est d'être
10e championnats d'europe d'aviron bram
était en équipe nationale mais sans être
à un très haut niveau
moi même je n'ai pas de mes yeux vu
pendant les deux ans où j'ai été en
équipe nationale de pratiques illicites
bon par contre j'ai quand même des
contacts avec des rameurs qui étaient
mes coéquipiers à l'époque où qui eux
ont fait une carrière et je sais que
certains d'entre eux indiquent qu' ils
ont été privé d'une médaille olympique
par des gens qui leur ont dit eux mêmes
avoir été dopés donc en 80 pour ne pas
citer d'autres exemples
le quatre de couple français a fini
quatrième à une demi seconde en quatre
de couple bulgare qui lui a fait 3e et
où les rameurs bulgares ont indiqué aux
rameurs français ce qu'il fallait faire
pour pouvoir être médaillés la fois
d'après c'était en 81 par contre si on
se ramène aux années
plus récentes il ya eu des cas alors moi
j'ai fait partie pendant douze ans de la
fédération internationale d'aviron dans
cette fédération la particularité était
on punit d'une exclusion à vie à la
première incartade en matière de dopage
dur avant que l'ama existe et on a eu
beaucoup de discussions au sein du
conseil pour dire est ce que cette règle
qu'on était quasiment les seuls à avoir
à l'époque et je vous parle de ça
c'était au début des années 2000 est ce
que cette règle est efficace ou pas moi
je faisais partie de ceux qui disaient
on condamne pas à mon entrée on laisse
la chance à chacun de pouvoir se
rattraper
la création de la maille du code mondial
antidopage a accéléré la procédure est
désormais la fédération internationale
d'aviron a comme d'autres fédérations
les mêmes règles qui sont celles de
l'ama et donc on est sur deux ans pour
un cas de dopage avéré à des produits
particulièrement nocifs
et puis la punition avis lorsque
il ya récidive que je peux dire aussi
c'est que dans le cas et il ya eu un cas
alors je ne sais plus si c'est il ya
quatre ou cinq ans mais le cadre de
plusieurs équipages russes qui ont été
contrôlés positifs et où la fédération
internationale d'aviron a indiqué
qu'elle n'accepterait plus de
d'engagement de rameurs aux russes tant
que la fédération russe n'avait pas
changé de dirigeant et la fédération
russe a changé de dirigeant changer
d'encadrement changer d'entraîneur pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'un minimum de
confiance permettant de reconnaître
comme logique le fait que des rameurs
russes ne peuvent s'engager donc même
dans le sport qui est le mienne il ya eu
effectivement des canons intentions ils
sont pas légions fort heureusement
est-ce qu'on lutte suffisamment je
l'espère on le fera jamais assez en tout
cas les rameurs se
conforte volontiers aux règles qui sont
indiqués je n'ai jamais vu
personnellement ni sur un bassin
nationale ni sur un bassin international
de récriminations à l'idée qu'il fallait
se soumettre à un contrôle
avoir après on inopinée ou autres donc
on va dire que les règles des politiques
antidopage sont parfaitement assimilé
dans le milieu ce qui pour autant ne le
garantit pas contre le risque zéro en
fait avec le risque zéro plus exactement
c'est vous qui qui fédérer l'ensemble du
mouvement sportif l'ensemble des
fédérations notamment des fédérations
olympiques
est-ce que vous avez parfois le le
sentiment d'une inégalité de traitement
entre les disciplines en matière de
contrôle en matière de sanctions etc
si vous croyez en la matière y a des des
progrès significatifs à apporter
je ne sais pas si on peut le dire en
termes de progrès significatifs ce que
je crois en tout cas c'est qu'il faut
tout faire pour éviter que l'on puisse
penser qu'il n'y a pas de traitement
égalitaire entre les uns et les autres
donc je suis favorable à ce que l'on
puisse imaginer une forme de cohérence
qui évite à penser que le traitement
serait laxiste pour les n est que pour
les autres y aurait une certaine
mansuétude à l'égard de ce qui se passe
ou cueillez pas de politique
suffisamment volontariste chez les uns
par rapport aux autres etc tout ça
correspondait au but de la fondation de
l' agence mondiale antidopage
mais il peut y avoir effectivement des
mesures qui permettent d'améliorer le
dispositif et les moyens existants
actuellement sont suffisants pour
atteindre les objectifs que vous écrivez
à l'instant donc de demander un
complément dans la question quand vous
dites les moyens existants c'est en
termes de coût en termes d'arsenal de
techniques de contrôle où arsenal
juridique de sanctions d'une part les
contrôles techniques et ensuite les
éléments de législation qui permettrait
et s'ils sont insuffisants d'améliorer
les choses
alors en ce qui concerne d'abord les les
contrôles et en particulier les
contrôles inopinés qui sont en moyenne
importants de lutte contre le dopage ou
où les stores à sion du passeport
biologique qui est une véritable carte
d'identité sur le plan de l'individu et
de et de sa de ce qui va permettre
d'inventorier tous les paramètres qui ne
doivent pas évolué au cours du temps
je pense qu'il faut il ne peut pas y
avoir de politique efficace si on n'a
pas les moyennes de l'amener peut-être
ce que on est dans une situation où on
doit aussi discuter de ce qui peut être
fait et on s'aperçoit à travers les
différentes des différents faits divers
liés
à quelques mises en cause de laboratoire
peut-être que
ça serait intéressant qu'il y ait une
incitation de de toutes les autorités
qu'elles soient gouvernementales
sportive médiatique économique a incité
les laboratoires en termes de mécénat il
ya une loi française qui est
intéressante sur le plan de l'incitation
à justement investir sur la lutte
antidopage qui qui qui a besoin pour
être un minima dans son action de 7 à 8
millions par an comme c'est le cas
actuellement pour mener à bien la
mission qui lui est dévolue par la loi
et on peut penser que un financement via
ceux qui peuvent aussi bénéficier de
d'une image améliorée à grâce à une
action de soutien pourrait effectivement
amélioré la capacité
ça représente un chiffre qui est pas
très important par rapport au chiffre
d'affaires de l'industrie pharmaceutique
alors ça n'a rien à voir avec tous les
aspects liés à la santé de l'ensemble de
la population mais il n'empêche que par
rapport aux dégâts que ça peut faire
notamment lorsqu'il ya un contrôle
antidopage sur un sportif qui est
déstabilisé dans le sens de tout ce que
cela peut induire comme comme aspects
négatifs vis-à-vis de la population
vis-à-vis du rêve vie des jeunes et
vis-à-vis de l'image du score je pense
qu'il ya une piste à explorer là dessus
mais pour répondre directement à votre
question il y aura effectivement part
jamais assez pour faire plus de
contrôles et faire plus d'actions de
prévention aussi pour lutter contre le
dopage et et lutter aussi contre la
suspicion de dopage parce que pour moi
je mets les deux toujours sur la sur le
même plan
merci et vous je crois avoir compris
dans vos propos liminaire que vous et
quartier c'est votre droit le plus
strict d'ailleurs la pénalisation de
l'acte au dopage fait le fait qu'à sa
tête se dopent ne doit pas être
pénalisés ou pénalisable vous j'ai bien
compris où j'ai mal compris
alors j'ai dit que je n'étais pas
favorable à une pénalité de type
sanctions disciplinaires prison ou
pénales par contre j'étais favorable à
une sanction financière
parce que quelque part il ya un
préjudice à l'égard de l'image du sport
et ce préjudice la justifie à un moment
que quelqu'un qui a pu s'enrichir grâce
à une performance sportive et même s'il
est sanctionné sur le plan sportif
parce que pour les stars le sportif
convaincu de dopage ne peut être
sanctionné que sur le plan sportif qui
me semble pas illogique qu'ils apportent
une contribution financière ne serait-ce
que à faire en sorte que dans le futur
qui est plus de moyens pour la lutte
antidopage indo cas il ya un préjudice à
l'image du sport qui est indéniable
ça me semble pas logique que il ne
participe pas à la réduction de ce
préjudice à l'intérêt de votre position
c'est d'abord qu'elle est original parce
qu'on a pas beaucoup entendu ça jusqu'à
présent et deuxième nom de votre part
c'est la première fois qu'on en parle
entre nous nous avons reçu déjà certain
nombre de responsables et c'était soit
la sanction pénale soir pas de sanction
du tout la solution intermédiaire que
vous proposez sanctions financières sous
forme d'amande ou pour réparation du
préjudice porté à l'image du sport de
manière générale c'est intéressant que
vous l'ayez confirmé merci de l'avoir
fait
toujours sur ce registre présidence jean
chaîne des contrôles et des sanctions
parce que là aussi nous avons connu des
appréciations divergentes entre les uns
et les autres
est ce que vous pensez justement que les
sanctions par exemple doivent donc
échappé au mouvement sportif ou parce
qu'elle doit être externalisés est-ce
que cela doive relever par exemple de l'
agence française de lutte contre le
dopage parce que certains dont on
considère que les fédérations ne peut
pas être à la fois juge et partie en la
matière
le souci dont vous avez fait l'écho des
bus qui était celui de comment on peut
faire en sorte que ce soit cohérent et
qu'il n'y ait pas de différence de
traitement entre les disciplines est
effectivement un des paramètres à
considérer dans le contexte actuel où
chaque fédération et responsabiliser en
matière de sanctions sportives
alors c'est bien qu'il y ait eu une
harmonisation des sanctions
c'est déjà un canevas important par
rapport à ce qui me gêne dans le
dispositif actuel c'est qu'on puisse
laisser à penser que certaines
fédérations pourraient être plus laxiste
que d'autres en matière de sanctions et
à un moment il y a
peut-être un intérêt à ce que ça soit
externalisés alors maintenant je vais
prendre des précautions dans le mond
externalisés pour définir ce qui peut
être une piste de réflexion
si on veut avoir un système efficace il
faut que l'on puisse le confier à des
gens qui soient des experts qui sont
expérimentés qui soit aussi des gens qui
soient choisis par le mouvement sportif
donc six domaines
on devait avoir une cellule formée de
personnes choisir imaginons même au delà
de manière paritaire entre la structure
gouvernementale et le moment sportif qui
serait en charge 2 l'important c'est
qu'il y ait à l'intérieur des gens dont
la compétence ne puisse pas être mise en
cause
et à ce moment là on ne pourrait pas
dire non plus que le pouvoir sportif
cent des filles il me semble qu'il faut
veiller aussi à ce que on ne dise pas
oui mais c'est un aveu de faiblesse ils
ont pas voulu
je prendre le problème à bras le corps
non le je crois que le problème doit
être pris à bras le corps avec un moment
sportif responsabiliser et responsable
mais il peut être responsable sans être
directement acteurs et donc par
l'intermédiaire du choix éventuel des
personnes qui seraient dans cette
commission où cette cellule on
l'appellera comme on voudra il pourrait
ainsi y avoir le lien entre les deux
sites une piste à explorer sion dis pas
que c'est la bonne solution je dis que
c'est une piste à explorer pour qu' il y
ait à la fois de la cohérence
en tout cas qu'elle soit maximale et
pour que l'on évite aussi parfois de
penser que certains sont mieux
structurés ou plus volontariste que
d'autres merci stéphane mazars oui
monsieur le président vous avez souligné
donc notamment sur interrogations du
président de la commission alors
l'intérêt de demander les comptes n'ont
point de vue financier donc à ceux qui
trichent
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le cnosf se
constitue partie civile dans des
procédures qui concerne donc des
sportifs qui se doper et qu'ils peuvent
donc être poursuivie devant des
juridictions alors au travers notamment
et la pénalisation et les poursuites de
de trafic de produits dopants
est-ce que tout tout à l'heure on a on a
auditionné donc le président de la
fédération française de cyclisme qui
disait que l'un dans les affaires qui
touchent le cyclisme systématiquement la
fédération française de cyclisme se
constituer partie civile et solliciter
les dommages et intérêts est ce que dans
les disciplines sportives qui relèvent
donc de
du chant du cnosf est ce que vous avez
vu cette volonté de vous constituer
partie civile est ce que ça pourrait
être une démarche qui pourraient être
entreprises
si j'ai bien compris vous l'avez dit
vous-même il s'agit de se constituer
partie civile à l'encontre de ceux qui
se livrent un trafic pas du sportif lui
même on est bien d'accord et la loi
punit celui qui se livrent au trafic est
pas le sportif
- je suis simplement indiqué qu'il me
semblait nécessaire que le sportif alors
pas tous évidemment mais certains ceux
qui ont été les plus impactants par
rapport à l'image du sport puisse être
poursuivi pour une sanction et je
précise encore une fois encore une fois
je suis pas juriste
donc je ne suis pas sûr que il ne puisse
y avoir que les sanctions financières
lorsque l'on porte plainte pour un cas
de ce type
mais si c'est possible je trouverai pas
inconvenant que quelqu'un qui a gagné de
l'argent voire beaucoup d'argent en
étant dopé et bien soit sanctionné
financièrement par rapport à réparation
du préjudice qu'il a fait subir aux bien
le plus précieux du sport qui est son
image quand même son image pour ce qu'il
apporte à l'être humain
donc moi ça me semble pas incompatible
voilà alors maintenant est ce que le
cnosf s'est porté partie civile ou post
porter partie civile
si une fédération est directement
concernée par un trafic et qu'elle le
fait ça n'est pas la peine que le cnosf
le fassent à sa place par contre la
fédération pourra toujours sollicité
l'aide du cnosf et c'est souvent comme
ça que l'on agit aussi par
l'intermédiaire d'une forme de
mutualisation pour que le cnosf soit
avec ses services juridiques à ses côtés
pour
l'aider à obtenir la réparation en
question mais encore une fois ce qui
existe actuellement dans la loi est
effectivement utilisées par la
fédération française de cyclisme et
c'est bien nous on n'a pas à rajouter
quelque chose ça ferait du trouble je
pense
si geof si la fédération le souhaitez
mais pourquoi pas
merci à la mairie oui monsieur le
président deux questions la première
vous dites que vous êtes favorable à des
sanctions financières
est ce que vous seriez favorable à ce
que les pardons vous nous dites vous
êtes favorable à des sanctions
financières
est ce que vous seriez d'accord pour que
l'argent récupéré à travers la
condamnation financière soit fléchés
pour la lutte contre le dopage sur un
fonds spécial pour un but contre le
dopage
mais pourquoi pas en tout cas je je
pense que ce qui est important c'est
qu'il puisse y avoir alors encore une
fois c'est avec s'est laissée à
l'appréciation d'un jury et ça ne doit
pas être dans un objectif systématique
mais qu'il y ait la possibilité d'une
sanction financière pour réparation d'un
préjudice celui de dégradation de
l'image du sport et la lutte contre le
dopage fait partie des éléments qui
permettent l'amélioration ou la garantie
du maintien de l'image du sport donc pas
de problème à ce que il ya un fléchage
sur la lutte antidopage
moi j'ai indiqué la participation de
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui me
paraissait être aussi une piste
intéressante par rapport à ce que ça
peut représenter en termes d'image
positive est ce que vous seriez aussi
favorable à ce qu'il y à un prélèvement
sur les recettes de certains événements
sportifs pour que ça fasse un appoint un
ajout au crédit sur la lutte antidopage
je pense que les événements sportifs
dits lucratif sont aussi des
éléments dont l'apport à la fois en
terme économique mais aussi en termes de
cohésion sociale sont incontestablement
des éléments centraux au niveau de la
société
il y a eu beaucoup d'éléments qui ont
été mis en oeuvre en termes de
solidarité ce soit la taxe sur la
retransmission télévisés et autres
il me semble que si on allait dans le
sens que vous indiquez on ferait un
parallèle qui pourrait être dangereux
entre la notion d'événement porter
médiatisé et le dopage est donc je n'y
suis pas favorable
merci afin madania question au moins je
pense que dans laquelle la lutte contre
le dopage
bien entendu il faut maintenir les
contrôles après les épreuves danse et
qu'il faut une fois fait très rapidement
sur venise est certaine efficacité et
deuxièmement on sait aussi que les
contrôles inopinés sont un des éléments
majeurs de d'efficacité à huit autres
dopage
or un certain nombre de représentants de
fédérations ou de sportifs ou de
personnes qu'on a pu recevoir ici nous
ont fait part de leur désaccord sur la
mise en place systématique de contrôles
inopinés qui serait pour eux des
contraintes pratiquement insupportable
dans le cadre de leur entraînement dans
le cadre de déchets des conditions fait
l'entraînement a su je peux pas
participer totalité entraînements parce
que bien contrôle antidopage
ou parce que quelle est votre position
là dessus est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que à un certain niveau quand on veut
lutter contre un fléau telles qu'aldo
pas il faut s'en donner les moyens
accu presse atom de contraintes
gfr une réponse en deux étapes la
première c'est que je ne veux pas mettre
en cause la représentation parlementaire
mais je vais quand même indiqué que le
citoyen que je suis trouve que on fait
parfois trop de lois pour que les 2 3 ou
4% ou 5% de gens qui à un moment ont
créé un événement qui peut être peut
être généré donc on fait une loi qui va
pénaliser les 95% qui le font bien leur
travail et et arrive à bien fonctionner
si je dis ça par rapport à la question
c'est pour indiquer que on va dire on
est jeune on pas le dire là on n'est pas
dans un contexte où il faut se faire une
généralité juridique voilà c'est faisons
en sorte qu' on ne sera pas dans la
pénalisation contraire et la deuxième
question j'ai oublié parce qu'il y avait
deux paramètres
c'est la deuxième partie de la question
s'était collé sur les contrôles inopinés
oui alors là aussi c'est pareil il ya
des fois où ça se passe parfaitement
c'est accepter moi je crois que c'est le
prix à payer je les dis au début le
système adams est parfois critiquée il
n'empêche que il y en a qui disent
j'y suis favorable on a toujours entendu
un type comme federer c'est pas
n'importe qui dire moi je trouve que
c'est bien que ça existe et que je me
soumettent donc il n'y a pas deux comme
ça c'est par autre chose que le souci de
montrer que la performance qui peut être
la sienne n'est dû qu'à son talent et à
son travail là où il ya eu quelques
critiques et moi je n'ai été aussi
l'écho c'est que parfois il peut y avoir
un excès mais encore une fois il faut
relativiser les quelques fois où ça a pu
se produire
par exemple chaque athlète doit indiquer
l'endroit où il se trouve tel jour dans
telles conditions etc
et c'est vrai que parfois médecin
préleveur peut arriver sonné à la porte
à sept heures du matin ne pas avoir de
réponse est pas atteindre suffisamment
de talent et l'athlète est localisé
comme n'étant pas présent et donc c'est
peut être l'objet de warning par rapport
à ça non réponse
un engagement qu'il a pris précédemment
en ça fait partie des choses que je
disais sur la loi c'est pas parce que il
ya peut-être deux ou trois pourcent de
cas qui se passe comme ça qu'on doit
faire une généralité
donc voilà c'est en tout cas pour
répondre de manière précise à la
question est ce que c'est le prix à
payer oui c'est le prix à payer aux
contrôles inopinés ah bah oui
incontestablement oui je n'ai jamais
émis le moindre doute sur la l'utilité
des contrôles inopinés et mêmes et même
le programme adams qui va au-delà de ce
qui a été fait précédemment pour les
contrôles inopinés parce que contrôles
inopinés quand vous parlez pas où
j'étais président on
donner le lieu de stage et puis les
médecins préleveurs arriver pendant le
stage
mais on n'avait pas à dire tel jour à
telle heure l'athlète est un tel endroit
là on est allé beaucoup plus loin que ce
que l'on faisait dans les années 90 mais
plus loin beaucoup trop loin
non non beaucoup plus loin j'ai
maintenant beaucoup plus loin mais
encore une fois si on est allé aussi
loin c'est aussi pour garantir la
probité du sport que les athlètes
pratiquent et finalement c'est aussi
pour certaines leur métier pour d'autres
leur passion
pour ceux qui dans ce métier c'est aussi
leur patient m
ça va de pair en général à ce rapporteur
oui monsieur le président je vous pose
cette question notamment parce que
maintenant l'action internationale du
sport relève du mouvement sportif
lui-même
ça fait partie des innovations récentes
il va y avoir dans quelques semaines des
élections pour la présidence de l'ama
comment appréciez vous que pensez-vous
de la candidature éventuelle d'un
compatriote
je vais parler bien évidemment de
patrick chamakh
non on s'est tous les six ans la
présidence de la marque 3 soit un an
représentant des autorités
gouvernementales soit en représentants
du mouvement sportif patrice amar a émis
sa son souhait son ambition de pouvoir
prétendre à la présidence de la mas il
il a toutes les compétences pour cela le
fait qu'il soit français n'est pas née
les marques d'appréciation favorable ni
défavorable moi je pense que sur le plan
de la lutte antidopage
certes la nationalité peut être
importante mais c'est surtout la
compétence de la personne donc patrick
est quelqu'un qui a l'expérience d'avoir
été le médecin du cio d'avoir participé
à toutes les commissions juridiques qui
se sont réunis au cours du temps pour
examiner tel ou tel cas donc au niveau
de l'expérience je crois que peu de gens
ont la même que lui au niveau de la
volonté et de l'engagement
il n'y a pas le moindre doute par
rapport à la qualité de l'un et de
l'autre et je crois que c'est surtout en
terme de personne qu'il faut juger
extrêmement intéressante sa candidature
et non pas simplement qu'en termes de
nationalité le fait qu'ils sont français
sont plus de fierté personnelle après de
fierté nationale mais mais c'est pas un
élément déterminant en soi une dernière
question parce que nous avions eus je
dirais ensemble le cnosf et le sénat la
volonté de mettre en place le passeport
sanguin précédé d'un groupe de travail
en vue effectivement de favoriser sa
mise en place à compter du 1er juillet
prochain
est-ce que vous pensez que l'on sera
prêt
sur les ports les palois enfin j'ai un
peu une caisse je n'ai pas regardé
l'état actuel des travaux et donc j'ai
un peu de mal à déterminer précisément
la réponse à la question si monsieur le
sénateur me permets de lui apporter les
éléments plus précis de réponse une fox
et pris connaissance de la réalité
exacte des travaux je préfère ne pas
répondre précisément plutôt que de
répondre quelque chose qui serait erroné
qu'on veuille bien me pardonner ils
viennent me dire discrètement l'oreille
il est absous connaissait pas les
grandes qualités je faillis dires du
père lozach mais qui prononçait
d'absolution comme ça en direct quelques
mots de conclusion si vous le voulez
bien président vous écoute si vous en
avez une
si vous le souhaitez
je crois sincèrement c'est vrai que il
ya des aspects pervers négatifs qui sont
préoccupants et qui menace l'existence
même du sport il n'ya pas que le dopage
la corruption la violence
d'autres aspects sociétaux qui
malheureusement existe le racisme le
nécessite que les autorités sportives
fasse tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir
pour en concertation avec les autres
parties prenantes aussi bien les
autorités politiques que le monde
économique que le monde médiatique et
tous ceux qui sont concernés par le
sport puisse apporter le maximum pour
préserver l'intégrité du sport
l'intégrité des sportifs
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est un bien précieux de l'humanité
et qui est un élément essentiel des
sociétés quelle qu'elle soit et quel
qu'en soit leur histoire mais que je
regrette parfois c'est que de la même
manière qu'eux on met plus facilement en
avant les trains qui déraillent que ceux
qui sont à leur parfois l'image du sport
soit ternie par quelques affaires qui
existe et il faut pallier alors que
elles ne représentent que une infime
partie de ce que l'ensemble des
pratiquants peuvent exprimer et que
quelque part et c'est pour ça que je
parlais tout à l'heure de sanctions
financières par rapport au préjudice
même si jamais jamais une sanction
financière ne réparera le préjudice subi
quel qu'en soit le
la victime il n'empêche que c'est pour
sensibiliser aussi au fait que ce qui
est dans le sport l'apport le plus
important ce qu'il apporte à
l'épanouissement de l'être humain et
quel que soit le niveau auquel celui-ci
le pratique ça ça ne doit pas passer au
second plan par rapport aux aspects
pervers c'est un peu ça on parle
beaucoup des aspects pervers c'est vrai
qu'il faut lutter contre mais ça n'est
pas l'essentiel de l'activité sportive
et fort heureusement donc mon job comme
celui de mes collègues c'est aussi de
promouvoir ce qui est positive dans
l'activité qui est la nôtre
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui a
pratiquement à les 80% des français qui
un jour ou l'autre ont été licenciés
dans un club qui a 15 millions de
personnes qui le sont actuellement et
que grâce à l'action de 3 millions de
bénévoles on peut faire en sorte qu'ils
aient des hommes et les citoyens grâce
au sport merci beaucoup se posent et
d'en mettre fin à notre après midi de
travail
merci d'avoir joué le jeu avec nous me
permettre je suis pas écrivain majeur
mais de temps en temps il faut bien
qu'on mette des idées en place dans un
livre alors j'ai eu le plaisir de
rédiger avec pascal boniface
un livre qui s'appelle le sport c'est
bien plus que du sport on a peut-être
entendu parler c'est à la fois
oria il ya quelques pages sur
l'expérience personnelle et la vie qui a
été la mienne mais il ya surtout
quelques perspectives qui ne peuvent pas
vous laisser indifférent par rapport à
l'organisation du sport dans notre pays
le fait qu'il a une importance
transversale qui me semble être
insuffisamment reconnues je rêve un jour
que l'on puisse organiser les jeux non
pas pour le plaisir de les organiser
mais parce que je trouve que le message
qui a été fait par nos amis londonienne
d'inspirer une génération est quelque
chose d'exceptionnel et que le vrai le
vrai problème que l'on a c'est que
domaine les jeunes fassent du sport
parce que le fait qu'il y en ait un sur
trois qui n'en fasse pas et un sur deux
dans les quartiers difficiles doit être
une préoccupation de tous les instants
j'ai commencé par ça et je pense qu'il
faut que je finisse par sa merci
ce message
voilà pour l'audition de